they never wanted the public to know
when we landed there were other assets
there at the Landing site or the crater
above it was quote unquote crowded with
these UFOs sitting there and I know this
for a fact
Buzz Aldrin knows that Neil Armstrong
knew it I tried to get Neil to come Neil
Armstrong to come forward but he's been
told if he ever talks about that he his
wife his kids and his grandchildren will
be killed they'll wipe them out so I
said look I'm not going to force the
issue but I know what happened when we
landed I know what was there I think at
a certain point it was decided maybe we
shouldn't pee going back so they they
after a few more events
they sort of wound down that Moon
project initially we were going to build
a a base up there and do all kinds of
stuff now keep in mind
it wasn't just extraterrestrial assets
there were man-made assets already on
the Moon yes ma'am